le 20 mai dernier la famille et les amis
de jérôme laronze demandait justice et
vérité lors d'une marche silencieuse
leur souhait connaître précisément les
circonstances de la mort du jeune
agriculteur
le gendarme auteur des coups de feu a
été mis en examen pour violences avec
arme ayant entraîné la mort sans
intention de la donner
il plaide la légitime défense une thèse
qui ne convainc pas les parties civiles
qui avaient demandé de nouvelles
expertises balistiques et pas d'une
demande des expertises complémentaires
importante pour pour nous qui nous est
refusé au motif qu'il n'a pas paru à la
juridiction utile à la manifestation de
la vérité
une décision de la cour d'appel qui
révoltent marie pierre larose la soeur
de l'agriculteur ou directement
catastrophé par cette décision parce que
bien malheureusement on sont comme le
disait moi j'ai en mémoire des paroles
du père durée ni frais zellers a pris
connaissance de leur donnant mon dieu en
dix ans la justice est aux ordres quand
et des gendarmes ou des policiers sont
mis en cause la justice et au sort moi
malheureusement c'est cette phrase qui
m'envahit aujourd'hui et on
n'abandonnera pas je veux dire dans ce
pays a dit éléments et ces éléments
devront être exploitées
la cour d'appel a également rejeté la
demande de la confédération paysanne
le syndicat souhaitait se constituer
partie civile dans le dossier il ne le
pourra pas une vraie déception pour
l'avocate du syndicat c'était une
volonté appuyée cette recherche de la
vérité
l'instruction de la fer se poursuit et
les proches pourraient demander
rapidement d'autres investigations
supplémentaires